enacting a deal at the UK and the EU
both hope will mend a relationship
frayed by brexit's main unresolved
question the status of Northern Ireland
Britain's foreign secretary James
cleverley welcomed the eu's chief
negotiator Maro sechovic to London to
sign the Windsor framework we've now
found a way to move forward we've found
a way to unlock the full potential of
what is a very strong and important
partnership between the UK and the EU
it's at British ports like Liverpool
where it will be implemented most
directly designed to address the anger
of Northern Ireland's unionists and
Westminster conservatives who said rules
governing shipping from the mainland
undermined Northern Ireland status as
part of the United Kingdom
former prime minister Boris Johnson's
brexit deal left an effective Customs
border between Mainland Britain and
Northern Ireland mandating strict checks
on Goods sent there under the new
agreement that will still be the case
for goods destined to end up in the
Irish Republic they will be subject to a
so-called red Channel across sea trade
but for a shipment of goods that's
guaranteed to remain in Northern Ireland
it will go through a green Channel
requiring just one piece of
documentation
the idea is even a mixed shipment of
goods from various suppliers to various
customers could be treated in this way
drastically reducing the barriers that
have kept familiar Products off Northern
Irish shelves but that doesn't mean that
this focus of post-brexit tension has
been resolved to everyone's satisfaction
some species of trees and plants for now
still won't be allowed into Northern
Ireland because of EU plant safety laws
the eyes to the right
515 the nose to the left 29 but the
bigger issue is political despite the
overwhelming majority in the UK
Parliament this week Northern Ireland's
Democratic unionist party and some
conservatives voted against the dup
isn't satisfied that a measure allowing
the assembly in Belfast to challenge
changes to EU law that will apply in
Northern Ireland goes far enough and
it's still refusing to go back into the
power sharing Administration
nonetheless a deal announced with great
Fanfare less than a month ago is now
ratified and moving ahead removing the
main obstacle to EU UK progress in other
areas like scientific cooperation Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera Liverpool